[Music]
have you ever had a dream Neo
that you were so sure was real
what if you were unable to wake from
that dream
world
and the real world
this can be you wanted to know what the
Matrix is near
it is the world that has been pulled
over your eyes to Blind you from the
truth what truth
you've been living in a Dream World Neil
what's up as long as the Matrix exists
the human race will never be free
your mind
what cold
show about this no
Mr Constantine I'd like to ask you a few
questions I know the circles you travel
in
the occult exorcisms easy though hero
that's dragon's breath
I thought you couldn't get it anymore
I thought that we could at least point
me in the right direction yeah okay I'm
sure
[Music]
please
what if I told you that God and the
devil made it wait for the souls of all
mankind no direct contact with humans
that would be the rule of just influence
see who would win demons stay in Hell
angels in heaven they called the balance
I need to see what you see
there's no turning back you see that
they see you understand
this is
[Music]
go to hell
saying goodbyes
sing hello
you think your wife can hear you no
a white ball
Maybe I'm Wrong
you're going to die
maybe not goodbye to you my trusted
friend
[Music]
a new day is Dawning
new ideas no rules no management we've
known each other since we
[Music]
who is this
Martin de gramo
challenge him to single combat with a
loose it's a way out
I don't sit at the table your family
does please pray for me
[Music]
man has to look his best when it's time
to get married
or buried
I'm going to need a gun goodbye my
friend
thank you
if you win
the table will honor its world
we will have your freedom
under the old laws only one can survive
failure to meet at sunrise
for results and execution
Last Words Winston just happened
yeah
I want you to find your peace but a good
death only comes after good life
you and I left a good life behind a long
time ago my friend
[Music]
so you are a dog I am the Batman
I'm not really great with animals yeah
I'm not really great with people
probably because of my traumatic
puppyhood that's the chart of my family
was taken from me as a puppy I was taken
from my family so I stealing myself my
emotions always check no one ever
getting past my impenetrable defenses
[Music]
that can't be sanitary
every day me and Suits hang out
literally worship the ground that dude
walks on technically he flies Batman
works alone except for Robin and Alfred
Commissioner Gordon my I.T crew whoever
Morgan Freeman played what do I have
here squishy Bruce
better be a
real toy or I will freak out
all right Pop Quiz airport gunman with
one hostage he's using her for cover
he's almost to a plane you're a hundred
feet away
what do you think shoot the hostage what
go for the good wound and you can't get
to the plane with her
clear shot you're deeply nuts you know
all right gentlemen what we have here
are 13 passengers in an Express Elevator
bomb's already taken out cables bomber
wants three million dollars or he blows
the emergency brakes anything else
that'll keep this elevator from falling
strike anywhere
anywhere time well Mr guest please sign
in why are they messing with me do they
think I'm doing this for fun
tell me again Harry why did I take this
job come on three more years of this you
get a tiny pencil a cheap gold watch
cool the game began
very exciting Jack some close calls huh
when someone put the city of Los Angeles
to the ultimate test a quiz Hot Shot
there's a bomb on a bus once the bus
goes 50 miles an hour the bomb is armed
if it drops below 50 it blows up what do
you do what do you do no are you in
short yeah why
he's the only solution we just got a
ransom demand from your terrorist says
he's ripped the city bus West Jack
where do you think stay under get off
get off
this is much better
everybody hold on
[Music]
thank you
Reeves Dennis Hopper Sandra Bullock a
quiz you have a hair trigger aimed at
your head what do you do
what do you do
ready for Rush Hour
when your wives suggested couples
therapy do you think this is what they
had in mind definitely
I mean we're a couple of couples right
Bill Ted enough of the delusions you
didn't time travel and you didn't go to
heaven and hell
here's a real idea for you the role
models to your daughters get real jobs
[Music]
Bill we've spent our whole life trying
to reunite the world and I'm tired dude
and Ted we have a destiny to fulfill
greetings my excellent friends do you
have a problem
step forward
a song created by Preston Logan
performed tonight will save reality as
we know it
oh good we better write that song now or
why can't we just go to the Future when
we have written
except won't that be stealing cheers
how is that stealing if we're stealing
it from ourselves dude
dude our dads are totally in trouble
you should help them out
[Applause]
away how's it going dude
we're putting together the most
extraordinary bands
hey you want to be in our van
oh this is so fantastic
we're gonna go talk to Dad is he playing
oh Scotty by himself dude he's cheating
hey death well if it is in the wild
Stadium
let's rock
excellent to each other and party on
dudes
[Music]
how you doing well you know dead and
we're in hell
you doing
you're kidding me he said that to your
face to my face and then what happens I
get real close right I'm like I don't
care which Cabbage Patch you're from
give me back my view Master before I
knock the dimples off your face
okay no you didn't you don't even care
man yeah you are I don't care bear
yeah you see a new movie trailer for
what you ain't see it say what what is
it ducky what they're making another Toy
Story movie no I thought those movies
were Don dog they made three movies did
make three movies this is number four oh
shoot oh I love the Toy Story wrong Toy
Story is mine yeah what about Buzz
Lightyear stuff I am Buzz Lightyear
Space Ranger
and then when he's like you are a toy oh
yeah that's pretty good that's what I
think he does do it do it to infinity
and your mom
what yeah that's not right you sure no
that's not right I'm pretty sure that's
it no no let me show you to insanity and
a blonde what do you even insane to
immunity and respond two in season two
infrequently hey guys you got it all
wrong it's to infinity and beyond
can't go to Infinity dummies it's
impossible
you're gonna go beyond Infinity you
don't know nothing about science
[Music]
foreign
he has in him
why do you win because I'm better
[Music]
I didn't come here to kill you owe me a
life
thank you
that's a nice dress thank you I like
your jacket thanks
I have our flight's on time oh it is
great
I'm sorry what was that what you just
took a step forward there I didn't yeah
you did you know you did and what's
funny is there's no way you can board
first because the only way you get bored
first is if you have a special need do
you have a special need yes
I need to be over there
what brings you to possible rules I'm
going to a destination wedding
so we're just the people you don't know
where to stick you might as well just
stick us together I don't want to be a
person you don't know where to stick
that's an issue wedding is presumptuous
they're in a Fool's Paradise don't you
believe there's someone for everyone
close I believe that there's nobody for
anyone
stand how even after Keith did what he
did to you you can possibly still be
mooning over here because you're a
monkey who doesn't understand The Human
Condition having met you I understand
why it's a condition
you know I'm not wearing anything under
my pajamas Why would you they're so
alluring
what is that I think it's a mountain
lion could it be a Jaguar what
difference does it make a cougar maybe
oh Jesus Christ
[Music]
how do you not install a pathway the
heels won't make it can you carry me
please what this is the slowest I've
actually been carried God you gotta be
quiet
[Music]
I'm up I'm up
you like that huh
nice ride nice
how much excuse me how much for the car
she's not for sale
Daisy
I lost everything that dog was a final
gift from my dying wife
[Music]
Jonathan you got out once you dip so
much as a pinky back into this Pond you
may find something reaching out to pull
you back in it's personal where'd you
get that car what does it matter
it's not what you did son it's who you
did it to
nobody
but nobody
is John
Wicked
[Music]
you working again no just sorting some
stuff out Tasker crew how many as mad as
you have
hey John
I thought I'd let myself in
people keep asking if I'm back
I'm thinking I'm back
I'm not afraid of John Wick
[Applause]
your laundry no one's not good I thought
[Music]
I love my life I love you so much Gary
I'll never forget the day we met
[Music]
me too
Daddy I'm home Gary Care Bear
no nope nope Gary's been snail mapped
[Music]
this summer The search begins friends
don't let friends go on dangerous quests
[Music]
with all new faces
hello call me Sage good name I'm made
out of sage and I am a sage so it works
out pretty well I'm Patrick my name
means toaster in Celtic pretty sure it
doesn't the most amazing places the lost
city of Atlantic City boy I hope we
don't lose focus look I wouldn't worry
about us losing you
cotton candy
[Music]
you can bet on put it on L Patrick
that's not an L that's a seven seven
starts with an L
that's weird the SpongeBob Movie sponge
on the run this is gonna be like a
bloody movie oh I love your sense of
irony Patrick thank you
I love my sense of ironing too
I'm looking for someone who assault for
you
banished from our lives
[Music]
oh
my God
[Music]
why did you come from me
those who enslaved you have taken over
our land
will not stand in our way
we believe you are the only one who can
help us
their army is infinite we are 47.
if we do this there's no coming back
the enemy will be watching
I know what you are you have no idea
I'm not afraid of you
should be
[Music]
thank you
your life belongs to us then take it if
you can
come on
hey Dad good morning William good
morning
[Music]
it'll be like it never happened what's
going on
William something's not right with me
tell me the truth
there was a crash
Todd
initiate
[Music]
I brought you back
there is a reason human cloning is
banned I'm deaf
we stole millions of dollars worth of
ionite equipment I hope you're ready to
go to jail
three subjects are our property
I didn't Define every natural law there
is just to lose you again
how could you do this
because
I love you
[Music]